ich fasse mal ganz kurz zusammen im märz
land ein gerichtsverfahren gegen
facebook vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof facebook missbrauche seine
marktmacht und wenn du unrechtmäßigen
datensammlung praktiken an so lautet
ganz grob die anklage vor wenigen
monaten geht dann eine mittelblockerin
an die presse und wirft facebook vor den
eigenen profit über das wohl seiner user
zu stellen kurz darauf gibt es zwei
globale technische ausfälle alle dienste
facebooks inklusive whatsapp und
instagram sind stundenlang nicht
erreichbar wieder einige tage darauf
tauchen nutzerdaten von 1,5 millionen
facebook usern im darknet auf und was
macht facebook ändert seinen namen und
kündigt ein wie ich finde
größenwahnsinniges und noch sehr
unrealistisch das projekt an das metall
wird also in diesem video geht es um die
absolut verständliche frage was zur
hölle ist da gerade los bei facebook
[Applaus]
radio ist eine börsennotierte stöhr
erst einmal muss ich sagen dass ich auch
vor diesem jahr schon kein besonders
großer wert von facebook war das hat
irgendwo zwischen dem kauf von whatsapp
und dem cambridge analytica skandal
angefangen ich war also bereits etwas
bei ist als ich all diese nachrichten
gehört habe um meine eigene meinung soll
es in diesem video aber natürlich wie
immer nicht gehen stattdessen habe ich
hier zusammengetragen was die fachwelt
zu diesen ganzen entwicklungen sagt die
quellen zu allen aussagen findet ihr wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
soll jetzt aber warum macht facebook das
alles und was soll dieses neue meter und
mieter versus überhaupt sein also meter
ist der neue firmenname für den
übergeordneten konzern diesen konzern
gehört unter anderem das social media
portal facebook und der konzern selber
hieß ursprünglich auch mal selber
facebook etwas kompliziert aber das ist
so ähnlich wie bei alfabet dem konzern
dem google gehört jetzt gibt es meter
mit all seinen diensten wie whatsapp
instagram und facebook.com selber die
sollen aber alle ihren namen behalten
meter bekommt auch ein neues logo und
einen neuen ceo mark zuckerberg
persönlich klingt nach ziemlich viel
aufwand für ein bisschen heiße luft denn
eigentlich ändert sich gar nichts so
richtig oder ist das alles ein
schnellschuss und von dem ganzen
negativen schlagzeilen abzulenken ein
schnellschuss ist es zumindest
wahrscheinlich nicht denn es gibt seit
jahren die vermutung dass facebook
seinen namenswechsel plan auf der name
meter kursierte schon als möglicher
kandidat auf der namenswechsel aber auch
die ganze zeit schon früher ich habe es
zwar dass ein 21 geplant war oder jetzt
aufgrund der skandale schneller
durchgezogen wurde das wissen wir
natürlich nicht zwischen dem ersten
hinweisen und dem tatsächlichen
namenswechsel verging auf jeden fall
nicht besonders viel zeit also kaum mehr
als eine woche um genau zu sein aber das
beantwortet nicht die frage was halt
facebook meter sorry davon außer dass
sie unter ihrem neuen namen natürlich
dass meter was aufbauen möchten was sie
auch als facebook hätten tun können aber
zum mieter werks kommt mit leichten
viele expertinnen und experten sind der
ansicht dass eine umbenennung bei einem
unternehmen nur wenig hilft wenn man
sich neu verkaufen beziehungsweise
referenten die leute nennen den
großkonzern hinter google ja auch immer
noch google und nicht elf am berg
vorteile kann es für facebook dennoch
haben mark zuckerberg zum beispiel kann
sich jetzt effektiv von den ganzen
facebook skandalen distanzieren denn er
ist ja der ceo von meter nicht von
facebook wer sich über facebook
beschweren möchte soll bitte mit dem ceo
dieser unterabteilung reden dass das
einer der gründe für den namenswechsel
und die umstrukturierung ist erscheint
auch gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich wenn
man bedenkt dass ein us
generalstaatsanwalt gerade sascha berg
persönlich für aktionen von facebook
angeklagt hat
auch wenn man sich die
unternehmensentwicklung der letzten
jahre ansieht ergibt der namenswechsel
irgendwie sinn facebook macht längst
viel mehr als nur social media da kann
man schon verstehen dass der gesamte
konzern von wa brillen bis hin zur
crypto währung nicht mehr heißen will
wie einen studierenden netzwerk trotzdem
hätte facebook meter vielleicht erst mal
seine zahlreichen internen probleme
beheben sollen bevor es versucht sich
neu zu verkaufen das zumindest meinen
expertinnen und experten also
vorausgesetzt dass mieter überhaupt
vorhat seine missstände zu beheben
manche stimmen vom juden auch dass das
einstige facebook mit dem neuen namen
seine probleme einfach nur unter den
teppich kehren möchte
und was ist jetzt dieses meter wird von
dem alle sprechen unter einem meter
works versteht man in der tech industrie
eine art vernetzte digitale universum
wie in der echten welt kann ich mich
dann nahtlos in verschiedenen räumen
bewegen und alles frei mit in alle
anderen bereiche nehmen ok klingt jetzt
vielleicht etwas abstrakt deswegen hier
ein beispiel ich könnte mir im meter
burst zum beispiel ein neues t-shirt für
meinen metallbörse avatar kaufen dieses
t shirt kann ich bzw ein avatar dann
sowohl morgens im büro tragen in das ich
mich als hologramm einwählen als auch
nachmittags wenn ich mich als avatar in
luigis auto setzte und mit meinen
freunden ein mario kart rennen fahren
alles ist miteinander vernetzt zentral
ist dabei dass das metall wird nicht nur
digitale räume verbindet sondern auch
die tatsächliche realität augmented
reality heißt das prinzip und das ist
ungefähr wie pokémon aber es gibt auch
virtual reality ich könnte mich also mit
meinen freunden sowohl als avatar in
einem völlig fiktiven digitalen raum
treffen virtual reality als auch meine
freunde als hologramm neben mich auf
meine echte couch setzen kommentiert
reality dass facebook so ein digitales
verletztes universum erschaffen möchte
dass kursiert auch schon etwas länger
das wort metaversum beispielsweise
bereits juli bei einem interview mit
mark zuckerberg mehr als 10.000 neue
leute sollen eingestellt werden um teile
des metallbauers aufzubauen
viel wissen wir trotzdem noch nicht
darüber wie dieses meter das genau
funktionieren und aussehen sollen sowie
in den provinz wahrscheinlich allerdings
nicht wenn alles so kommt wie zuckerberg
es sich erträumt dann müsste ich an der
strandpromenade von san francisco
entlang joggen können obwohl ich
eigentlich zu hause auf einem laufband
stehe wie genau das alles technisch
funktionieren soll verrät meter leider
nicht einiges scheint sich um spezielle
brillen zu drehen die man sich aufsetzen
muss um das meta bus überhaupt zu können
mieter bastl wohl auch schon daran aber
sascha burg gibt zu dass noch einige
jahre ins land fließen werden bevor es
in dieser umfassenden form überhaupt
technisch möglich ist derzeit gibt es
nur einzelne digital räume als
prototypen
müssen wir also traurig sein dass es
noch so lange dauert bis wir ins meter
wird abtauchen können ich persönlich
denke eher nein denn das ganze erinnert
mich sehr an ray player für alle die es
nicht kennen es geht um eine ziemlich
triste welt in der die menschen in ein
digitales universum abtauchen um dort
ein gutes leben leben zu können der
bösewicht in dieser geschichte will aber
die kontrolle über das digitale
universum erlangen um die gesamte
digitale welt mit werbung zu übersehen
und damit er die digitale welt in die
reale holen möchte kann die werbung auch
hier überall platziert werden und genau
das könnte meter so schön finden an
seiner schönen neuen welt max band krieg
von der university of oxford befürchtet
zb das meter die alleinige kontrolle
darüber behalten wird was im meter wird
getan und programmiert werden darf er
bezweifelt dass der konzern zitat etwas
aufgeben würde was ihre position als
maßgebliche anbieter von werbung im meta
war's gefährden könnte und das ist jetzt
mein gedanke auch für alle anderen
funktionen der digitalen welt könnt ihr
meter ja irgendwann gebühren verlangen
oder sie möchte sich zum beispiel mit
mehr als fünf menschen am tag
unterhalten kostet geld du möchtest dem
digitalen meeting mit seinen kollegen
beitreten vorher musst du dir nur noch
zwei werbe clips ansehen was schon bei
youtube gegen erich ist könnte in deiner
zweiten realität allgegenwärtig werden
und ich denke die skandale der letzten
jahre haben auch er hat zweifel daran
gesät ob ein die realität erweitert ist
digitales universum von einem konzern
die meta programmiert werden sollte oder
ehrlich gesagt auch nur von irgendeinem
konzern auf der eigenen website wird
meter damit sogar zu den sustainable
development goals beizutragen allerdings
die neuesten enthüllungen von den
whistleblowern frances augen lassen
neben all den anderen skandalen und
gerichtsverfahren
nicht gerade hoffen im zweifel stelle
mieter immer den eigenen profit über das
wohlergehen seiner nutzer so die
kernbotschaft der whistleblower in
zwei beispiele die hat facebook in
eigenen studien festgestellt dass der
facebook algorithmus innerhalb weniger
tage in einer abwärtsspirale aus hass
beiträgen enden kann und dass instagram
für das körpergefühl von jungen mädchen
und frauen schädlich sein kann dagegen
getan hätte facebook aber nichts oder
zumindest nicht genug so werden laut
augen 87 prozent der ressourcen des
konzerneigenen an team des informations
teams auf die usa konzentriert dabei
sind nur zehn prozent der facebook
nutzer aus den usa in indien oder dem
gerade in gewalt versinken den äthiopien
sind zum beispiel aber hetze und fake
news mutmaßlich starke treiber der
wachsenden gewalt
meter sagt zu alledem dass sich die
enthüllungen nur die negativen teils
veralteten seiten heraus geprägt hätten
sie würden facebook interne vorgänge nur
einseitig beleuchten facebook versuche
eine balance zwischen dem recht auf
meinungsäußerung und der sicherheit der
nutzer zu wahren
ob mieter oder irgendein anderer konzern
ein digitales universum aufbaut dass
eines tages teil unserer realität werden
könnte ich stehe dem ganzen skeptisch
gegenüber denn wenn wir schon eine
schöne neue digitale welt aufbauen
wollen wir die dann nicht lieber selbst
mitgestalten mit stimmrecht und wahlen
und so und sie nicht von irgendeinem
unternehmen gestalten lassen erst recht
keinem das für gerichtsverfahren
allmacht ansprüche und datenlecks
bekannt ist an dieser stelle einmal
vielen dank an merck die es uns möglich
gemacht haben dieses video hier zu
produzieren merck ist ein weltweit
agierendes wissenschafts und technologie
unternehmen das auch an
zukunftstechnologien arbeitet wenn auch
an keinem meter würde stattdessen haben
sie einen podcast den future talk hier
geht es um die neuesten entwicklungen
aus der welt der wissenschaft und auch
darum wie technik entwickelt werden muss
damit sie den menschen tatsächlich hilft
eine folge dreht sich zum beispiel darum
wie man in zukunft mittels technik
medikamente ohne tierversuche entwickeln
kann oder wie big data anders als bei
facebook die welt besser machen kann
ich persönlich mache ja besonders die
folge wo es darum geht die wissenschaft
für uns alle zugänglich gemacht werden
könnte ob in silence nämlich ich hab ich
den link zum podcast und in die video
beschreibung gepackt hört er gerne mal
rein ansonsten wie immer vielen lieben
dank fürs zuschauen und in diesem sinne
bleibt neugierig